security is Somalia's biggest challenge
to help the government extend its rule
throughout the conflict torn country the
European Union is working on
strengthening the army the --use
training mission has operated for three
years in Uganda but has now moved to
Mogadishu eutteum somalia is the fast
and most significant boots on the ground
as far as the EU is concerned in in
Mogadishu and in Somalia around 3,000
Somali soldiers have been trained but
much work remains to be done the Somali
forces are in a developmental stage I
mean it must be remembered that there
was a situation for 20 years where
Somalia was recognized and identified in
the international lexicon has been a
failed state it is now a you know
recovering state so therefore the state
of play with the Somali forces mirrors
those 20 years and the new developing
situation but they are making
significant progress the Jazeera Camp
where the training will take place is
almost ready at the strategic level
advisory teams are already working with
the defense minister and defense forces
chief
the basic training is set to begin here
soon the Somali troops and officers will
be housed in the camp's 130 buildings
here - security is a top priority and we
are creating creating a safe safe area
it's a military thing - greater freedom
of movements some barbed wire
construction some watch towers some
Hesco Bastion layers so that's the
smaller state we create a real garrison
for those people over there
there is now a an opportunity to make
significant progress as far as the
establishment of the democratic process
within Somalia to support the federal
government and to ensure that Somalia
and the Somali people have what some
might suggest is perhaps one of the last
chances to get the security situation to
establish rule of law and the democratic
process within Somalia